[Music]
and ever since i turned 13 i've been
doing my own thing making my own moves
24 7 365. i wear what i want
say what i want and i will not hesitate
to do a spontaneous cartwheel if i feel
so moved
not to brag but being 13 means i'm
officially a grown-up at least according
to the toronto transit commission good
for you
oh about that hustle am i right
breakfast is ready
no sugar
[Music]
porridge
this isn't happening this isn't
happening
what's going on honey are you sick is it
a fever a stomachache chills
constipation
wait is it that
did the
did the red peony bloom no
maybe
huh um
seven
my mom cuts his hair at the salon and i
felt it it's very soft whoa i have some
yeah abby hook her sister up
ew he looks like a hobo a hot hobo may i
remind you what real men look like oh
four town yes
jesse went to art school
[Music]
remember
[Music]
yeah but tickets to four town are like a
bajillion dollars and devon's right here
and free
four
[Music]
i'm gonna let go and you're gonna be
chill
[Music]
are you a werewolf no what
he's a red pepper sick you're so fluffy
you're so fluffy i've always wanted a
tail free up abby quit it
made what the heck happened it's just
some you know
inconvenient uh
genetic thingy i got for my mom i mean
it'll go away
eventually
maybe
i
hate this
i'm sloppy i'm smelly my mom won't even
look at me and
no poor town
when are they coming may 18th they just
announced the 18th there's no way this
will be gone by then just just go
go become women without me
it's gonna be okay no it's not i'm
i'm a freak
just
just leave me alone
[Music]
let's go
it's true but they don't turn my tummy
the way
let's go
i'm maylin lee i wear what i want say
what i want 24 7 365.
i know it's a lot
but i don't got time to mess around
oh about that hustle am i right
this is gonna be the best year ever
and nothing's gonna get in my way
[Music]
breakfast is ready
[Music]
is everything okay
i'm a gross red monster
[Applause]
oh look at me stay back this happened
already what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas are you kidding me this
little quirk runs in our family
[Music]
you're so cute sick i've always wanted a
tail i'm a freak we love you mae you're
our girl
whoa you're you
any strong emotion
will release the panda abby hit me
[Music]
do you know how dangerous this is you'll
get whipped up into a frenzy and panda
all over
my whole life i've been perfect little
maymay but maybe i like this new me
mama's girls
it's gonna be me
this film is set in 2002 toronto think
bright pastels and scrunchies graphic
tees and bucket hats may is our spunky
13 year old protagonist nerd and proud
of it
y equals negative 4.
she has to balance family life social
life friends life and school life this
is grade eight i don't got time to mess
around
they sent me based off of myself and my
ride or die dork squad
and she is the apple of her mom's eye
they are basically joined at the hip
give me five yeah i play the character
of ming who is mei's mom ming is a
little i would say hyper vigilant but
loves her daughter deeply
everything changes for may when she
wakes up one morning
and she's a giant eight foot tall furry
red panda
this isn't happening
[Music]
she's feeling like this is the worst
thing ever her friends are right there
to be like it's not the worst thing ever
i'm a furry digging time bomb of
awesomeness and now you can come with us
to four towns i'm never gonna let you
cry
[Music]
four towns are the world's greatest boy
band mae's first crush her mom would not
approve why are they called fourth town
if there are five of them when we got
approached about this project we left at
the opportunity it's literally been the
most fun we've had writing
from the music the animation
the characters and then the story itself
it's a very specific vision coming from
domi
what makes turning red so universal is
that it really taps into that awkward
time in all of our lives i'm finally
figuring out who i am everyone goes
through it and you will survive and
thrive
[Music]
writing a song has literally been the
most fun we've had writing
they're super excited to say that billy
eilish and phineas o'connell are writing
the music for four town
the glue that holds these characters
together and turning red is this boy
band called foreign yes
when we got approached about this
project we left at the opportunity it's
true it was very exciting
[Music]
songs in the style of early 2000's boy
band it's the really catchy melody and
harmonies and claps and choreography
phineas is actually gonna be one of the
members of four town the main ingredient
in these boy bands is like these young
heartthrobby teens that kids fall in
love with just repairs hey
are like really talented too
we wrote three songs one that confidence
the confidence booster
[Music]
one that's more of a love ballad
and then one that is the hit song that
everyone knows
[Music]
her friend's passion for four town it
really resonated with me just because i
was the same so accurate of how it feels
when you're that kind of fan operation
iv town shakedown is about to commence
there's like this bond when you have
people that feel the same i just i love
the film
[Music]
all right
[Music]
you